اكتشاف جديد يجذب العالم الى تراث مصر
الفريد في مدافن منطقه سقاره ارض الاسرار
والاكتشافات الكبيره حيث هذا المتحف
المفتوح الذي يضم بين جنباته معظم اثار
التاريخ المصري القديم جاء الاعلان عن
اكتشاف بعض من تلك الاسرار يعني للكشف عن
اكبر
ورشتي تحنيط ادميه وحيوانيه في منطقه
صقاره
الورشه اللي احنا بنتكلم فيها احنا واقفين
عندها دلوقتي دي الادميه
سراير اللي كانت بتتغسل فيها الاجساد
بنلاقي فتحه سوارا نسميها المزراب اللي
كانت بتنزل الميه بعد الغسيل
لقينا الادوات اللي استخدمها المصري
القديم في فتح الجسد عشان يطلع معده
وامعاء وكبد ورئتين لينا بعض من الاواني
الكانوبيه اللي كانت بتسمى اواني حفظ
الاحشاء
الورشتان المكتشفتان تعودان الى اواخر عصر
الاسره الثلاثين وبدايه العصر البطلمي
بينما تعود المقبرتان الى عصري الدولتين
القديمه والحديثه حسب ما ذكر علماء الاثار
وقد عثر في ورشه التحنيط الادمي على اوان
فخاريه منتشره في جميع الحجرات وكميه
كبيره من الكتان وماده الراتينغ الاسود
التي كانت تستخدم في التحنيط اما ورشه
تحنيط الحيوانات فقد عثر بداخلها على بعض
الدفنات الحيوانيه مختلفه الاشكال
والاحجام الى جانب بعض الادوات الخاصه
بتحنيط الحيوانات وتعود المقبره لاحد
موظفي عصر الدوله القديمه من الاسره
الخامسه وكاهن من عصر الاسره الثامنه عشره
الدوله الحديثه اضافه الى ذلك عثر على
مجموعه من التماثيل من الخشب والحجر
والتابوت من الخشب الملون ومجموعه من
موائد القرابين والتمائم واجزاء من اختام
طينيه ومجموعه من الاواني الفخاريه ونفذت
مصر عمليات تنقيب واسعه في منطقه سقاره
وغيرها من المواقع القديمه في السنوات
الماضيه ما ادى الى عدد من الاكتشافات
المهمه وتامل القاهره ان تساهم هذه
الاكتشافات في جذب مزيد من السياح الى
البلاد